we've been talking for years on the
program about how to best get health
care to everyone and I'm using that
phrasing as opposed to saying Medicare
for all or nationalized health care or
whatever else because there are actually
different ways of getting health care to
everyone and many different countries at
our level of development have different
systems all of which relatively
effectively achieve that goal and this
is something that's really important to
be informed about because the right
likes to give these out of context
anecdotes and use general talking points
to try to sort of meld all of the health
care systems in different countries
together and derail the conversation
I'll give you some examples and then
you'll understand what I mean we hear Oh
healthcare for all is bad because people
wait forever for care in Canada or
healthcare for all is bad because the
UK's public hospitals are terrible or
whatever and the point that I want to
make to you today is that there is no
one health care for all is bad talking
point that works because these countries
all have different systems when in the
United States we say the rest of the
developed world has figured this out
that's true
but in different ways and we've
mentioned before the difference between
for example single-payer systems and
nationalized health care those are two
different things the whole point here is
everybody has access to care quality
care at a price that they can afford
sometimes the price being zero at the
tail-end but paid for through taxation
but the systems are very very different
now I am relatively agnostic as to how
we get there
what I care about is what is the system
cost in total and is it affordable for
the end users what does it do in terms
of access and what is the quality of
health care that is provided and wait
times would be part of what I would
consider quality so let's talk about
some of the differ
is that that are sort of out there
Canada and the UK
both have single-payer systems but in
Canada as we've recently talked about
because of a procedure Rand Paul is
going to be undergoing in Canada in
Canada the providers are still
overwhelmingly private although they
often receive money from provincial
governments the insurance is
single-payer in Canada at the province
level but the health care delivery
system has not been socialized and taken
over by the government Canadians will
often pay for additional coverage
through jobs for prescriptions dentistry
optometry the government ends up
spending about 70% of all health care
expenditures then we look at a country
like Britain we look at the UK health
care itself has been socialized or
nationalized you can say meaning that
the government is providing most of the
care through the national health
services there is a private system in
the UK only about 10% of people have it
but the government does about 80% of the
healthcare spending but again the
government is providing a lot of the
care through hospitals and clinics that
they run oh we've talked before about
the Singapore approach which is very
different actually did an interview
about the Singapore health care system
in Singapore there is cheap and
sometimes free care made available in
government-run hospitals
workers contribute about 37 percent of
their wages into mandated savings
accounts those accounts aren't just used
for health care they can also be used
for a housing for insurance for
investments for education and employers
also contribute a piece to it so it is a
sort of taxation plus government-run
model that is still more market driven
than some of the others you have the
opportunity to pay more for private
rooms or more luxurious care if you can
afford it or if that's important for you
since so much runs through the
government in Singapore the government
will go
she ate drug prices they will be
involved in setting doctor salaries etc
it's way cheaper than the United States
four point nine percent of GDP versus
17% of GDP in the United States it's
also a much more efficient system but it
does have some shortcomings which we can
dig into a little bit later let's look
at Australia Australia has free
inpatient care at public hospitals and
they also have a voluntary private
insurance program the government in
Australia is paying about 85% of
outpatient services the rest is made up
with this optional private insurance if
you look at France in France everybody
is buying health insurance that is sold
by nonprofits they don't have or it is a
non-profit healthcare industry it's
financed through taxes and it covers up
to 80% of healthcare costs then it's up
to you if you want to get insurance for
that additional 20 or 30% that's not
covered or pay for it out of pocket then
we look at a system like Switzerland
Switzerland has a universal health care
system where everybody has to buy
insurance from nonprofits 30% of buyers
get subsidies based on income as a
percentage of GDP it's a little bit more
expensive but they have extraordinarily
good health outcomes as well as access
to care in Switzerland so all of this is
just to get us to today's conversation
about Germany because Germany's health
care system is not discussed nearly as
often as it probably should be and over
the weekend there was an op-ed written
in The New York Times about the health
care system by Jamie DAW who's a
Columbia public health or health policy
professor and the professor professor da
says that the German system is better
Germany's system achieves universal
coverage for most services it costs less
than Canada's obviously it cost less
than the American system which is one of
the worst while simultaneously being one
of the most expensive
and it is not a single-payer system
importantly it's a multi payer system
and it has a really interesting history
and have spoken about some of this
before the system Germany has right now
goes back to Otto von Bismarck in 1883
and we actually spoke to former Cigna
executive wendell potter on the program
about this and he talks about it in his
book deadly spin the united states at
one point between World War one and
World War two was actually heading in
the direction of this Otto von Bismarck
German system but the timing of it was
such that the United States didn't want
to seem to be doing the thing that
Germans are doing because Germany was a
growing enemy of the United States the
system was abandoned the idea for that
system was abandoned in the United
States and we ended up with the system
we have now which is truly a disaster
the system Germany has you have to have
health insurance okay there are about a
hundred private nonprofits that are
insurers that you can choose from
workers and employers are sharing the
cost through payroll taxes similar to
what a medicare-for-all system might be
in the United States and the government
finances coverage for kids and
unemployed people now important detail
just because the cost is shared by
employers and employees doesn't mean
that the plans are tied to your employer
or to having employment and because the
system is funded through progressive
taxation access is actually based on
need not one's ability to pay or how
much you contribute is based on your
income rather than whether you're
healthy or you're not healthy and
there's a sort of genius element to this
which is that all of the taxes for these
programs are collected centrally and
then they're distributed to the
nonprofit insurers on the basis of the
health of the people that are members so
let me give you an example if you're a
non-profit insurer and the people you
are insuring tend to be more sick than
another non
ensure you will get more of that money
that is centrally collected and managed
by the German government in this central
fund in total they spend way less per
person than in the United States and in
many other countries that have other
forms of universal health care but
importantly they're not limiting access
to care that people need which is often
a talking point we hear about some of
these systems the right loves to say
care is rationed in a lot of these
countries number-one care is also
effectively rationed in the United
States in other ways and it's also just
not true that in these systems you don't
get the care that you need you get the
care you need there may be less urgent
procedures for which you might have to
wait a little longer than you
potentially would in the United States
but that doesn't mean people aren't
getting the care that they need and this
gets us back to the Bernie Sanders
proposal this is actually very similar
to what Bernie Sanders has proposed
which is using payroll taxes both on
employees and employers the difference
is that in Germany the money is going to
nonprofit insurers instead of a
single-payer system and not only in
Germany but also in Austria and the
Netherlands they have had serious
reduction to the cost of care down to
Medicare levels which is considered to
be something good to aspire to in terms
of cost of care levels that we have here
in the United States the other really
interesting element about the German
health care system is that it gets
everyone coverage it doesn't stifle
innovation it still removes profit from
health insurance which I don't believe
should be there as a social democrat and
it maintains choice which is what a lot
of people fear will be taken away under
some government-run systems so no system
is perfect they're basically all better
than what we have and it's really
important to understand that the talking
points that the right loves to use on
this simply don't apply in general
because every country has
different system in terms of Bernie
Sanders and Medicare for all my
suggestion would be we don't need to be
overly attached to Medicare for all
Medicare for all has some issues one is
that people who have Medicare in the
United States 80% have additional
coverage according to a recent study
they're either having Medicare plus some
kind of employer plan Medicare plus
Medigap insurance some people are poor
enough that they have Medicare plus
Medicaid and there's a few other things
in there so once we understand that
let's remove the sort of emotion from
the entire thing let's look at a system
like Germany's at the same time that we
consider Medicare for all type systems a
nationalized system like the UK has a
system that is more like Canada's all
paths forward should be considered a
once again I am in general agnostic as
long as there is a direct path to moving
to another system because every single
developed country has a better
functioning system at a lower cost than
the one that we have I want to hear from
you about this are you preferential to
the German system you prefer the British
system the Canadian system if you're
particularly attached to Medicare for
all let me know why I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show